i'm julian hyde i'm going to be speaking
about morale a functional query language
today
i'm going to post the slides at my
twitter account
so
you don't need to take pictures of the
screen
they'll be posted right after the
presentation
so
imagine that you
need to index the web
or you have
a million documents you would like to
build a text index on
um
so here are the files
and what you want to do is break them
into individual words
and
for each particular word you want to
build an index
that says
has contains all the document ids that
contain that word
or
to simplify a little maybe you just want
to count the number of occurrences of
the words in all those documents
so this is a classic problem
classic distributed systems problem
and
the distributed system that you want to
build in order to do this efficiently is
going to look something like this so
you want multiple workers that are each
taking a set of documents splitting them
up into words
shuffling the words
so that all all occurrences of the words
beginning with a go to a the same
reducer and all the words that begin
with p go to another reducer
and then those reducers are going to
write out the
sorted index files
and if we simplify the problem a little
bit we end up with the the well-known
word can problem where we're not
actually storing the document ids we're
just simply counting the number of
occurrences of each word
so this problem this this problem word
count
it first arose as far as i know in the
mapreduce paper around 2005
and it was arguing for this kind of
distributed system and arguing for
a particular
programming model called mapreduce to
solve it
i'm bringing it up here because i
the problem we're interested in is data
parallel programming
parallel meaning that you are processing
the same input but you have multiple
workers that are working on that input
and it's
some people have called it
embarrassingly parallel in other words
the workers don't need to communicate
with each other as long as you are able
to divide the work into partitions of
data each worker can work on a
particular stream of data
and not interfere with the other workers
which makes it you know very very
scalable
of course the problem is to recognize
[Music]
those streams of data that can be
processed independently
so it's for solving batch processing
problems or perhaps incremental
streaming problems
the input is it's working on large and
mutable data sets um
and uh one particular feature of this
that drove you know the
mapreduce model and things like hadoop
and spark is that the these jobs are so
big that there's a significant chance of
hard some hardware failure
failing during the execution
so
in mapreduce the way
that they did this is they
surprisingly i think at the time it was
very surprising they just they turned to
functional programming as a way of
expressing this problem
and they said let's suppose the system
provides a function called
mapreduce
and you the programmer supply with a map
produces a large complex function that's
in fact a framework right many thousands
of lines of code
and it's a distributed system but you
the programmer write two functions a
mapper function and a reducer function
which
in the case of the word count problem
the mapper function is to take a
file or a line of the contains multiple
words and split it into the individual
words and you pair each word with a
count which is which is one
um and then the reducer takes a
list of words
um
and
a list a list of words all of which have
the same key
and sums up the counts
um
you put those together
really you're using the framework to
glue together these two small functions
you've written you end up with a
solution to your problem and it's a
solution that runs in a you know
efficient scalable
parallel framework
um that's fine if you're a
c programmer or a python programmer but
it's not so good if you're a sql
programmer and
um
and you know a lot of people looked at
these systems and said well these are
clearly these are it's kind of like a
query
can we do this in sql and the answer at
the time was no you can't
um there's a couple of things that make
this difficult to do in sql
one of which is that
sql doesn't handle nested collections
very well
because it has this
hard distinction between a table which
is something you can put in the front
clause of your sql statement
and a an expression that you can put in
the select clause or the where clause
so you have to use this
this word these words lateral table
to say i want you to treat this
expression split d dot text
treat it as a table expression not a
column expression
and i think only really really advanced
sequel people know how to do this and
the other thing is um and in my view
that's just like an unnecessary feature
of the sql design to create two
different kinds of expressions that can
only occur in different places
and the other is you need to use a
defined function and sql you can do use
it to find functions but you have to go
to a different language define it
add that user defined function to your
class path restart your engine whatever
it's you have to leave the sql language
in order to accomplish this
so i'm going to be talking about a
language called morale
which solves this problem in three lines
i am presuming that you've
you've defined the split function
elsewhere but as we'll see you can do it
in a few lines in the same program
so
i've already given you the answer i
think the answer is morale but
what are the options here
you know for a while i was looking at
how do i extend sql to have user-defined
functions
um to have functions as values uh
improving the sql type system so it has
things like polymorphism
um oh yeah let's write if we're going to
do you know general purpose computation
in sql we're going to need to write an
optimizing compiler for sql that can do
things like tail recursion and
elimination that kind of stuff
or
and you know since sql is a 50 year old
language that's rather it's rather a
tall order
the other thing the other approach is
why don't we take an existing functional
programming language
and make relations a first class object
in those in that language you know build
them into the language the same way that
let's say floating point numbers are
built into the language which means
making the language aware of the
operations you can do on relations
i'm not just talking about adding it to
the standard library i'm talking about
building it into the language
we need a way to map external data into
this if we're going to do database kinds
of problems we need a way to make this
program aware of relations that are
stored in say
a mysql database or that are stored in a
distributed file system
um and then we write need to write a
query optimizer not a
you know the other kind of optimizer the
the something that does the kind of
optimizations that sql optimizers do if
we do that then we get all the nice
stuff that's in modern functional
programming
functional programming languages like
algebraic types pattern matching and so
forth
so a quick straw poll so i get a feel of
this audience so
who in the room has written
any sequel
in the last six months
all right
who in this room has written
uh code in a functional programming
language like haskell or arkamal or
standard ml in the last six months
okay okay so i saw about 50 and now
we're about 40 on that one
uh okay that's good i don't know whether
these are two like competing factions or
whether it's the same people that raise
their hands both times
anyway what i am trying to do is i am
trying to bring all that functional
goodness
to the sql users
without making them run away and horror
and go i'm not using this it has braces
in it
so that's my goal
uh let me cut to the chase here and just
describe
like in one in one page what morale is
so that we can cut through all of the
you know
marketing
i'm just going to read this morel is a
functional programming language it is
derived from standard ml
and is extended with list comprehensions
and other relational operators like
standard ml morale has parametric and
algebraic data types with hindley milner
type inference morale is implemented in
java and is optimized and executed using
a combination of techniques from
functional programming language
compilers and database query optimizers
so
if that makes sense to you can leave now
so standard ml is a choice that i think
needs to be justified um
so here's the kind of the family tree of
functional programming languages with
lisp at the top
um
ml was started in 1973 and became
standardized around 1983 and things like
how skull are and akamal are derived
from it
um
we've also got languages in the kind of
the lisp part of the family tree-like
scheme enclosure
and then you've got these kind of hybrid
languages like scala and c sharp f sharp
which have kind of
mixed parentage of
from functional languages and also from
a declarative
from procedural languages
so
i made a conscious choice to use
standard ml
because um
fantastic as haskell is
there's a lot of extra stuff in haskell
the type system is very rich there's a
lot of stuff that allows you to you know
like loan out comprehensions that allow
you to do algebraic operations that
makes the language just simply
intimidating and so
you know
i think over time morrell may actually
may absorb some of the features from
haskell but my goal was to produce
something that was
uh
really concise like a sql program you
very very
very rarely see types mentioned in the
sql program
you know the type inference system
standard mls type system is simple
enough
that
you very rarely need type annotations
and that was that was kind of what i was
going for here
as for whether you know standard ml is a
eager functional language haskell is a
lazy language i haven't actually decided
yet whether
morel is eager or lazy
so i'm being meta-lazy in making that
decision
um
so
um
and also morale is a
it's a language it's a very young
language it is still evolving part of
the reason i'm here is to say come work
with me on this start bringing your use
cases let's shape the language
so nothing is set in stone
you know the the key idea is
i've explained to you already and then
where do we go with this
i'm also an open source guy i mean morel
has
developed open source but my other work
that i do on calcite and so forth is
open source and i see the real benefits
of developing this as a
collaborative community effort
and kind of the wisdom of crowds
approach so please
if you feel feel the urge to help please
get in touch
the target audience is sql users as i
said which implies certain kinds of
simplicity in the language
i'm de-emphasizing
i think i've said the word monad once
i'm de-emphasizing those complex aspects
that easily get pulled in when you're
talking about functional languages
i think they're all there that they kind
of the subtleties and nuances are there
but i'm trying not to
you know
talk about that up front
um
it's been a very interesting exercise um
so my work main work in apache cal site
is to do with query optimization
traditional sql query optimization i
think there's an awful lot that the
compiler the programming language
compiler community can learn from the
query optimization community and vice
versa and this is a really good test
testbed to see how those approaches fit
together
and
a very interesting thing that comes up
is what i call functional programming in
the small versus in the large
so
by in the small i mean you're writing
this particular function and you're
worried about tail recursion or memory
management or whatever
functional programming in the large
which was introduced in this mapreduce
paper is the idea of using functional
programming languages as a way of
plugging together components and you're
not so much worried about what's being
allocated on the heap as does the whole
system compose in a in a manageable way
quick intro to standard ml
if you know how skull and so forth this
probably will be
very straightforward
standard ml and morel have a read eval
print loop which means this text
disappears on the screen
the hyphen is the prompt
hello world is the expression and then
what's below it is what the system
prints and so it's a nice easy way to
you know
so we're looking at hello world which is
a string one plus two are working on
integers we've also got reals
uh
lists um
lists with polymorphism so you can have
a list of any type variable um
functions are a built-in type
you know lambdas um standard ml uses fn
where haskell would use backslash
you can have tuples which are basically
like anonymous records
so
one comma a is a tuple of type in time
string
and then you've got records with named
fields
the record type is
actually one of the key reasons i went
for ml because
haskell
at least most variants of haskell don't
have
support for record types built in as i
understand
so you define variables val x equals one
it's not really a variable because when
it's its value is set forever you can't
reassign x
um
[Music]
but there's no better word
in the programming language community
besides variables
val is odd here i'm defining a value
um whose value is a lambda so it's
exactly the same as the line below it
where i use the fun keyword to define a
function so
fun is just syntactic sugar for defining
a
value whose value is a lambda
and then i'm applying this is odd
function to x and it says yes one is is
is uh
is odd and then lastly the let construct
which allows me to define some temporary
values and then evaluate an expression
ml has
algebraic data types defined using data
type which you can think of as a
tagged union or something like that
so i can say a tree has three different
subtypes empty leaf and node
this is polymorphic meaning it's a tree
of any data type that you want
in this i'm going to instantiate it here
with ins and so each of those words
becomes a constructor
so like leaf7 reading from the right
creates a int tree with one element in
it
and so the whole expression there will
create a tree with five elements in it
um
and
with the algebraic data type it's very
natural to write a case statement to
basically exhaustively you know you've
got three branches in that case
statement you can handle empty leaf and
node
and
you can easily prove that you've covered
all of the cases
and one interesting thing about cases
when i write
node
ilr
i'm actually declaring those variables
at that point
i'm declaring variables and assigning
them at the same time as i'm pattern
matching so those are actually the
declarations of those variables
so case not only matches patterns but it
kind of deconstructs objects as it's
going
and then
yeah so the fun is also you know you get
there's a variant of fun which is
shorthand for case where you can define
the function with you know
many different uh forms and case will
it'll automatically generate a case
that
dispatches to the right version of it
so
in ml the relations
i use the word relation and list
interchangeably i know they're
technically different
ml has higher order functions so
function like filter which takes a list
and a
a function that returns a boolean and
will return a subset of that list
where the that function evaluates to
true
so higher order function is something
that takes a function as an argument or
perhaps returns a function as a result
so filter and map are built into ml in
many functional languages
and
a lot of people have noticed that
this is equivalent to a sequel
so the where clause in sql
has a very similar effect to the filter
clause
and
this is
kind of not an accident
it's just that in order to write that in
ml i have to write list.filter and this
complicated looking lambda expression
if i want to do joins so
here's a join expression in the in the
sql joining amps and depths with their
where they have the same department
number it now turns into seven lines of
ml list dot map and so forth
if you read it from the inside you see
you you're
reading from
the emps
relation then you're using flatmap to
read from the department's
all of the
all of the department records and then
you're applying a filter to filter out
the ones that are
not the same so
we're doing relational
programming here but it's very verbose
and it's upside down
so
in morel
i aim to make those kinds of operations
first class
so
since morale is a superset of standard
ml this program is valid morale as well
but i added a new expression to
morale that isn't in standard demo which
is this from expression
and it has sub-clauses wear and yield
so from i'm saying
you can think of it like a for each loop
in in a
you know
in java or whatever
so it is going through the amps
collection and it is successively
binding e to each
each record in the emps collection and
then for each amp it's going through the
depth collection and binding d so it's
doing a
you know nested loop here and then
applying where
um
filtering the things out so you could
think of this as doing nested loops or
you can think of it as a pipeline of
relational operations you it doesn't
really matter what it it
how how it does this is an
implementation detail
um
and then lastly um
i added some syntactic sugar to morale
so you didn't have to use this
pound depth no this
this accessor function for finding your
particular field
so i allowed you to write e.d no to
access the depth no field of the e
record
so this starts to begin an awful lot
look an awful lot like sql
the select clause is the first thing in
sql and it's the last thing
in in morale and i think everyone
acknowledges that's the way sql should
have been in the first place
other than that
and the fact that i choose lowercase
keywords because i don't want this to
look like cobol
there we are
so let's go back to word count i
promised we'd come back so this is the
full working word count
solution so i was able to use the let
clause to define a temporary function
called split
um
and i'm i'm building this you know
from the from the primitives so
um i am
uh let me see yeah so i'm using the
string.stra built-in function
that explodes a string into its
constituent characters
and then the i'm able to define a split
function
i'm sorry string explode is the thing
that converts a string into characters
so now i've defined this split function
from first principles i can then use it
um and this thing now looks an awful lot
like a sql query
so
oh and here it is running um it works
so this is where this distinction
between programming in the small and
programming in the large comes in
so
programming in the small is this you
know you're working in individual
characters and you know you're writing
recursive functions and so forth
um
it's good to have that in your back
pocket
but most of us are not implementing
quick sort and regular expressions we're
just using libraries for that and so
we hope that it's built into the
language but we have this ability to
write you know low-level low-level code
if we want to
and then i call this functional
programming in the large
so
the contribution of morel is to put
those
both kinds of programming in the same in
the same language
which gives the opportunities for the
optimizer or the yeah compiler whatever
um to kind of see see the the the whole
problem from beginning to end
but
you still want to use this for
programming in the large and so you'd
still like to be able to you'd like to
be able to define this function once
and then run this
large scale program on 100 compute nodes
and morale makes it possible to do that
let's just drill into some more more of
the features here
um so um
when you define a function in
morel
um
so here's a function called ms2
which runs a query or a from expression
the from expression returns a bunch of
records and in fact one of the fields in
the record this comp field is actually a
lambda so ms2 is a function that returns
a relation that contains a function
and that's what i mean about functions
being first class objects you certainly
couldn't dream of doing this in sql
right you you're you can have
i guess you can have uh like
points and geo geologic
geographical regions and spatial data
inside your sql data set and i guess you
can have xml documents but i've not seen
a variety of sql where you can actually
has have a function as a value in your
relation but you know why not right it's
20 21.
um so
so that's this idea of making functions
as values you know pervasive throughout
the language
the other thing about this is a
um
a compil a functional language compiler
will take this this function and if i
use mp2 um
it will or in fact if i use comp as well
it will try and inline it it'll say
it'll say do i have a definition of m2
which is going to be the same every time
i call this in which case i'll unline
this thing
so it will cease to be a function call
anymore
and that gives the opportunity for some
significant
optimizations
turns out that kind of expansion is
exactly what every relational database
has been doing since 1980 which is
called view expansion if you define a
view it doesn't
evaluate the view and get the records
and pass it on to the rest of the
statement it expands the view the same
way a c compiler would expand a macro
so
there's an example of functional
languages and query optimizers kind of
doing the same thing just giving
different names for it
um and yeah there it is it works so uh
so in this particular query i've decided
to call comp with um passing it the
value a thousand so this
probably the compiler can can inline
this because it knows that comp always
has the same definition
so
there's various clauses of the from
statement
each of which represents a particular
relational operator and we can chain
them together so here's a rather
contrived example where we
um
read employees and then we sort them and
then we apply a where clause um
sorry then we then we compute some
additional stuff you know we compute the
the name length field
then we apply a filter where name length
is greater than four
we
aggregate using the group construct and
compute a couple of aggregate functions
and then we apply another filter and
then we finally project the results
so
in sql you can't
have
you've got to limit you know there's six
possible clauses in a select statement
and generally you can only use three or
four of them in this case in morale you
can basically check continue changing
these as long as you want to
so let me just take this step by step
and you know initially we've got the
fields department number id and name
and then after we apply the order
operator the results change the the the
order of the results change but we still
got the same fields
when we apply the yield expression we've
got an extra field available the name
length field becomes available
so as you can see each step in amoral
from statement is basically making
more
a different set of variables available
and so
you know when i'm applying this where
clause we can use the name length field
which is which was available previously
the group
expression radically changes the the the
because because we're folding together
multiple records
the individual fields of those records
unless they're in the group clause those
individual fields like the name for
example is no longer visible after the
group
but
and then we can also compute some
aggregate functions in this case we're
counting the number of fields and
records in the group and summing the
name lengths
so this stuff composes really nicely
um
just a comparison
uh the the there's the morel program uh
the sequel is
of a similar length you can see the
nesting is extremely complicated and you
have to read it inside out again
you can think of this as i said as a as
a for loop in a procedural language like
java where you start off the outermost
loop is the four
you know iterating over the amps
relation
it gets complicated very quickly but if
you want to you can think of it as
you know binding you know the the name
and name length and id fields and then
doing some stuff inside the loop
so now calcite
apache calcite is the project i founded
about 10 years ago it's an apache
project
calcite is an implementation of
relational algebra
and you'll see in a minute why why we
decided to bring calcite into morale
calcite is a toolkit for building a
database management system it's used for
example it's the query optimizer inside
hive
it's also powers apache beam and the sql
implementation of beam
and it is designed not so much as a
product
more as a toolkit
so naturally a lot of pieces of it are
pluggable
a particular interest is that the the
rewrite rules the power the query
optimizer are pluggable as well we've
got about
200 built-in rules but people add new
rules all the time
i should call them transformation rules
and
many parts of it are optional but the
relational algebra is really the core of
it the orange ellipse there
so quick intro to relational algebra for
those of you who are not familiar with
it
this is how calcite would take a query a
select query a reasonably complex one
and you kind of read from the bottom up
so the first thing it does is it scans
the employees and departments tables
applies
runs them through the join operator and
then runs that the results of that
through the filter operator and then the
aggregate operator
so you can see there's a lot of
parallels with the the morel from
statement there
the way calcite works the big
contribution calcite makes is
well it has an implementation of
relational algebra but it has rewrite
rules so if you take a look at the
filter and the join over there
what we're doing is we're joining the
employees and departments
together
and then we're throwing away all
employees who are
younger than 50.
we can do that earlier on right we we
know that we can throw away the
employees under the age of 50 before we
do the join which means the joint has
less work to do
so you represent that as a rewrite rule
they we we call it push filter through
join rule that can basically transpose
those that's an algebraically valid
operation because it is always
you know before and after that
transformation will always produce the
same results
so a query optimizer
works based on
by having lots of these rewrite rules
and applying them
using dynamic programming guided by cost
and the rewrite rules are the cool thing
about them is they're
independent of each other so each rule
works
does the right thing in isolation and
when you compose them and you put 200 of
them in a bucket and apply them all to
the same query they don't interfere with
each other they're still all
individually valid and therefore the
whole thing is valid
you add a cost model and an engine that
does dynamic programming and that's how
query optimizers are built
so
we brought in apache calcite into morale
and the first thing we needed was the
fact that when
um
when you set up a calcite system
you kind of
mount these external data sources
so that they look like
in calcite's parlance they look like
schemas they look like
foreign database connections
when we introduced this into morale
we actually made them just look like
objects
so food mart in morale if you if you if
you launch morale and it's backed by
calcite
the fact that food mart is a schema in
calcite means there will be a top level
value called food mart in morel and its
value is a record
and the the fields of that record are
the names of the tables that are inside
that particular database
so
if i write scott.mp
um scott is the database depth is a
particular relation in it and therefore
scott.dept has four rows
so of course this is not really in
memory in morale
it's but i can still write queries on it
um
and as far as the morale language is
concerned it doesn't care whether it's
external or internal so i can write this
expression
from d and scott.dept where not exists
and you can kind of see it maps directly
to a sql statement
but as far as morale semantics are
concerned it might as well just be a set
of you know records in the list
so
if we set hybrid to true this tells the
morale compiler to consider
implementations of this that use calcite
relational algebra
and
tries to tries to generate a plan using
relational algebra and so this is what
will come out as the plan so this is
this is a calcite plan calcite all of
these things it's a logical projection
of a logical filter so calcite hasn't
decided
how it's going to execute this yet
calcite might decide to
generate a spark program to execute it
but
you know this is the starting point for
calcite to do what it does
so the optimization is this i mentioned
this this interesting
kind of
collision of the two different systems
so relational query optimization applies
to the relational operators
and
you have transformation rules that match
particular operators and there's
probably about 10 core operators i
showed you earlier the one that matches
a filter on top of the join there's
another one that matches a filter on top
of a project and so forth so the
transformation rules match those
patterns and
re basically reorder the relational
operators
and it makes decisions based on
statistics if it has statistics and
relational query optimization is
incredibly good at like whole program
optimization i mean pushing a filter
through a join or converting a pushing a
union into a join or something can
result in the program running a hundred
times or a thousand times or a million
times faster these these are kind of
everyday results from query optimizers
functional programming optimization are
they're often
much more
smaller benefits
um
but you know definitely affect things
like the amount of memory that's
allocated
the size of the the the stack
and so forth
so it's just been interesting i can't
kind of go into all of the details but
it's been interesting finding out
optimizations that exist in both places
that have you know different names
and then optimizations that are kind of
genuinely new
um
the big picture
um
why am i doing this i think the so the
word count example is
it's interesting because it has um
uh it's a convergence of programming in
the small and and programming in the
large
the the goal of word count was to
introduce this new compute model
um
you know the the mapreduce compute model
and the idea of a distribu of a
distributed system
running little fragments of user
code in a massively parallel system
so
neither of the these are two kind of the
two existing compute models that that
existed let's say 20 years ago you've
got the functional programming model
that allows you to write kind of cute
recursive functions and stuff for
factorial function and all the rest
and then
you've got the you know query systems
like the sql systems that allow you to
do large computations but it's not too
incomplete you can't do general purpose
programming
so
the mapreduce and
work basically took the functional
paradigm into data parallel systems
and the sql community that i was a part
of at time we took it as a great threat
that people were doing
our kind of problems solving them in a a
you know a functional programming way
there's been relational programming in
the functional language community with
things like list comprehensions and
monad comprehensions in in languages
like haskell
um
that you can kind of see the
relationship but the the problem with
that is that those looked alien to
people that were writing sql queries
so um
well they they look kind of similar but
there are very few sql programmers that
were prepared to cross over to haskell
plus it didn't run on a distributed
system
so what we've tried to do in morale is
kind of create these links more of an
explicit link between the good things of
the query system which is query
optimizers and so forth and the ability
to run on you know large parallel
systems
uh integrate that more closely with the
the functional programming language type
system and and and so forth
so i see morel is this opportunity to
unify
the all of these various ideas
and
i encourage you to try it out and come
and work with me
so in summary morale is a functional
query language
it has a rich type system
inherited from its
functional programming
uh parentage um it's as concise as sql
um but it is also too incomplete it's a
general-purpose language
it combines relational query
optimization and
lambda
functional programming optimization
techniques
it executes it natively executes in a
java interpreter but it can generate
programs for
data parallel engines
so
i don't think we have time for questions
here
but i'll be outside the door and we'll
happily chat for many many hours as long
as you guys want to talk so
[Applause]
[Music]
you